ashfield in europe helped european eu
one of asf he uses it and european eu
on
in spite of mobility passive of
discord
what what has teplice twice fioutch
and hexa chicks backbones francs room
it's a fright all afrikaans anthony
blanc  a tout pour antibes date is not
your eyes distinguished by twin twisters
soft [ __ ] dominating willy jean louis
do believe with no humanist philosophy
as i would have refused not to
deal with the greek case would have been an
unforgivable weakness a
multiple repetition error
if  the commission had not done what it
did
in business said yes completely
the security and borders to a wrestler
and is to be trend all very clearly
a good score and the cumulative
footnote signs and he did you know  how
to be done by this world as a binding
global climate deal we have also
carried out over the past year a
certain number of reforms
in my eyes substantial so old
european let's not give up let's
continue